Transcriber: Rana Karjy
Gözden geçirme: Emel Çırakoğlu
Herkese merhabalar ben Rachel.
Kısaca Rachel Araz Kiresepi
Hem adım zor hem biraz soyadım da zor.
O yüzden kısaca Rachel.
Her mesleğin parlayanları,
starları vardır.
Ben de bugün kendi mesleğinizdeki
starlığınızı keşfetmeniz için aslında
kendimi anlatmaya, size birazcık da
olsa ilham olmak için geldim.
Notre-Dame Sion Fransız Lisesi mezunuyum.
Ardından Sabancı Üniversitesi'nde okudum.
Aslında Sabancı Üniversitesi'ne ilk
girdiğimde Görsel İletişim Tasarımı
bölümüne girmiştim.
Reklam yazarı olmak istiyordum çünkü
insanları güldürmek istiyordum.
Böyle değişik kurgular yazıyordum kafamda.
Değişik senaryolar.
İşte beğenmiyorum, tekrar çekiyorum
böyle, sürekli olarak proje
geliştiriyorum kafamda.
Ancak üniversitede çok çok
değerli bir öğretmenim,
hayallerimle okuduğum bölümün
örtüşmediğini karar verdi ve beni çok
kibarca bir dersten sınıfta bıraktı.
O derste benim okulumu tam 1 sene uzattığı
için tabii ki sıkıntılı bir
dönem yaşadım.
Aileme de dedim ki ″Ben dedim
üstten ders alıyorum″ dedim.
Onlara da haber vermeden
bölüm değiştirdim.
Tam vaktinde işte yaz okullarına giderek
tam vaktinde Sabancı Üniversitesi
Yönetim Bilimleri bölümünden mezun oldum.
Böyle mezun olduktan sonra üniversiteden
tabii hepimiz kendimizi böyle birer star
zannediyoruz ve diyoruz ki işte yani hiç
kimse, ben ve iş bulamayan bütün
arkadaşlarım öyle zannediyorduk.
Mezun olduktan sonra işte bir kolumuzdan
bir şirket çekecek, diğer kolumuzdan
diğer şirket çekecek.
Biz de kahvemizi yudumlarken hangisinde
çalışsak acaba diye düşüneceğiz
diye düşünüyordum.
Ama dediğim gibi diğer tüm mezun
arkadaşlarım gibi iş bulamama
sıkıntısıyla yüzleşince hayatın acı
gerçekleriyle tanışmış olduk.
Benim içinde çok mutlu olacağımı inandığım
böyle güçlü, sektöründe lider
kurumsal bir firma vardı.
Ben de oraya iş başvurusunda bulundum
LinkedIn üzerinden.
Sonra geri cevap gelmedi, insan
kaynaklarından bir mail adresi buldum.
Emin olmamakla beraber cv’mi
yollamaya başladım
o İnsan kaynakları mail adresine,
cevap gelmedi.
Dedim ki herhalde bir yanlışlık var
yani hani bana dönerler görseler.
Aradan günler geçti gelmedi, cevap yok.
Ben de dedim ki print ediyim çıktısını
alayım cv’min ve insan kaynaklarına
elimle bırakayım
Hani gözden kaçıyor derim.
Hani hiç değilse görürler,
o kurumsal firmanın adresini
buldum internetten ve dedim ki
danışmaya gittim beni dedim
staj görüşmesine çağırmışlardı dedim
cv’mi getirdim ben de size.
Onlar da dediler ki şu an burada değiller,
bütün insan kaynakları toplantıda dışarda
ama ben masalarına bırakayım.
Günler geçti hala cevap yok.
Yani o kadar istiyorum ki
hiçbir B planım yok.
Başka hiçbir yere, hiçbir
firmaya CV yolamamışım.
Tek seçeneğim ve şansım ve beni
hayallerime yaklaştıracak kurum
olduğuna inanıyorum çünkü.
Aradan vakit geçti.
Tabii ki içimde de hem bir hayal
kırıklığı var hem böyle
hani bu düzene de aslında
biraz sitem ediyorum.
Diyorum ki,
″Yani Fransızcam var, İngilizcem var,
istedikleri bütün programları biliyorum.″
Hani nasıl olabilir?
Hani olumlu ya da olumsuz,
hani bir çağrılmaya, görüşmeye
gitmek istiyorum.
Ondan sonra bir mail hazırladım capstock
açık bir şekilde, biraz sitem
dolu bir mail işte.
Neden çağırıyorsunuz?
Bir görüşmek, tanışmak istiyorum, bir iş
görüşmesi yapmak istiyorum sizinle diye
ve gözden kaçırmamak için o mail adresine
yaklaşık 15 defa mail attım.
Gelen kutusunda biraz fazla
yer kaplamak için.
Ertesi gün beni aradılar, iş
görüşmesine çağırdılar.
Önce staja girdim daha sonrasında
da işe girdim o firmada.
Satın alma planlama ve
ME departmanında çalıştım.
Kurumsal iletişim ve pazarlama
departmanında çalıştım.
Daha sonra da Balenciaga markasının
Türkiye marka temsilciliğini yaptım.
Bu hem benim için hem onlar
için bir ilkti.
Çünkü ilk defa benim kadar genç biri
bu tecrübeyi, bu pozisyonu yapıyordu.
Çok da güzel seneler geçirdim.
Gerçekten,
akademik olarak hiçbir yerde
edinemeyeceğim bir tecrübeyi
orada hani benim için
bir hayat okulu gibi o
iş yerinde öğrendim.
Çok güzel bir çevre edindim.
Tam o dönemde de markalar kendilerini
biraz böyle dijitale yöneltmeye
çalışıyorlardı.
Kafalarını dijitale doğru çevirmek
istiyorlardı ama kimse açıkçası ne yapmak
istediğini bilmiyordu.
Daha o firmanın bir online
satış sitesi de yoktu.
Ve tam o dönem hatta kurulmuştu bu sitede.
Ben de dedim ki kendimi dijitalde
bir yer edinmem lazım.
Bunu nasıl yapacağımı bilmiyorum ama risk
almam lazım bir şekilde ve kendi zamanımı
yönetmen lazım.
Kendi adıma yatırım yapmam
lazım bu dijitalde dedim.
Avukat bir anneyle, yüksek mimar mühendisi
bir babanın kızıyım ve bu kadar
böyle tabelalı meslek sahibi ebeveynlere
aslında bu dijitali anlatmak birazcık zor.
Tam olarak ne yapacağımı, ne yapmak
istediğimi çünkü aslında ne yapmak
istediğimi de bilmiyordum o zamanlar.
Ve babama dedim ki Baba dedim,
ben fikir satmak istiyorum.
Hani fikir satmak istiyorum, insanları
aynı zamanda güldürmek istiyorum,
gülümsetmek istiyorum, pozitif
enerji vermek istiyorum.
Yani bir şekilde bu kılıfa uyan bir
meslek edinmek istiyorum dedim.
Hem onu hem de kendimi ikna ettim ve o
kurumsal şirketten beş senenin sonunda
ayrıldım ve dedim ki ben sosyal medya
danışmanlığı yapacağım, markalara sosyal
medya danışmanlığı vereceğim.
Ama tabii danışman olmak
için ne gerekiyor?
Bilgi gerekiyor.
Ama ben de sadece ilgi kısmı var,
ilgiliyim ama bilmiyorum hiçbir şey ve ne
yapmam gerektiğini de bilmiyorum.
Yurt dışından makaleler okumaya başladım
sosyal medyayla ilgili.
Hani neler oluyor bu platformda,
neler yapılıyor?
İşte Instagram o dönem çok
güçlenmeye başlamıştı.
Kurumlar bunu nasıl yönetmeli?
Sayfalarına ne içerik koymadılar, ne
fotoğraf koymadılar, ne mesaj vermeliler,
bunu ne kadar ciddiye almalılar gibi gibi.
Ve işte etrafımızdaki tanıdıklarımıza
ailece restoran sahibi,
mimarlık ofisi sahibi.
Rica ettim, dedim ki ben sizin Instagram
hesabınızı yönetebilir miyim diye.
Onlar da tamam dediler.
Çünkü zaten kendileri yönetmediği için
kendilerinde bir fikirleri yok
bu konuyla ilgili.
Instagram bilmiyoruz yani hiçbirimiz,
tamam dediler ve onları yönetmeye
başladım ve kendimi çok özgür hissettim
tabii ki o dönemde ve yaklaşık 15-20 tane
farklı markaya tabi bir şirket kurdum.
Resmen tek kişilik bir ajans
haline dönüşmüştüm.
Çok da iyi gitti o dönem.
Ve kendi zamanımı yönetebilmeye
başladığım için yani daha esnek çalışma
saatlerim olduğu için davet edildiğim
markaların lansmanlarına
gitmeye başladım.
Ürün tanıtımlarına gitmeye başladım,
koleksiyon sunumlarına gitmeye başladım
ve daha çok markayla tanışmaya
başladım bu şekilde.
Sonra günün birinde, ha bir de şunu da
eklemek istiyorum, tabii ki ben bunu
yaparken kendi Instagram'da da
çok özen göstermeye başladım.
Yani mesela Google'a giriyordum diyordum
ki en iyi işte soruyordum sürekli en çok
işte beğeni alan filtre nedir, en
çok beğeni gelecek etkileşimi
yüksek saat nedir?
Yani sürekli Instagram'da ilgili
araştırmalar yapıyordum ve kendi
profilime de çok özen gösteriyordum ki ben
herhangi bir markaya ben sosyal medya
danışmanıyım dediğimde ne
yapacaklar girecekler bakacaklar benim
profilime, benim profilim onlara
bir CV oluşturacaktı.
Ondan sonra günün birinde, bir
marka geldi bana ve dedi ki.
Hatta marka ismini de söyleyebilirim.
Trendyol.
Benim kendi adım altında yaptığım ilk
işbirliğiydi, bundan altı sene önce.
Dedi ki bana o marka ″Biz sana bir elbise
vereceğiz ve x lira bütçe vereceğiz.
Sen de bu işte bununla bu elbiseyle
birlikte fotoğraf çekilceksin ve
Instagram’ına koyacaksın.″
Dedim ki bu inanılmaz bir şey gerçekten.
Hem elbise benim olacak,
hem bundan para kazanacağım
hem de en sevdiğim işi yapacağım,
içerik üretmek ve
fotoğraf çekip bunu koymak.
Tamam dedim, yapacağım, yaptım ve bu
şekilde markalarla çalışmaya başladım.
Tabii ki bunlar da birbirini
çekmeye başladı.
Farklı markalar gelmeye başladı .
Global markalardan davetler
gelmeye başladı.
Gerçekten globalde ve yayınlanan
işbirlikleri yapmaya başladım ve hem
üretmeye başladım hem de
kazanmaya başladım.
Ve inancımı yükselten ödüller de alınca
böyle bu kendi sektörümde
ve kendi alanımda.
Dedim ki tamam ben doğru
yerdeyim ve mutluyum.
Hem üretiyorum, hem çalışıyorum,
hem içerik üretiyorum her gün.
Bu arada tekrar yeni bir şey
öğrenmeye çalışıyorum.
Kendimi geliştirmeye çalışıyorum,
değişmeye çalışıyorum,
dönüşmeye çalışıyorum.
Çünkü bu dijital dünya o kadar hızlı,
kendini yenileyen ve
dönüşen bir platform ki sürekli
biri bitiyor, biri açılıyor.
Popülerlik dengeleri sürekli değişiyor.
Yani yolun başından beri aslında bütün
düşlerimi çekim yasasına teslim ettim.
Olmak istediğim yeri.
Her gün düşledim.
Her gün insanları gülümsetmek istedim.
Bu arada nasıl gülümsetiyorum
kısmına da gelmek istiyorum.
Benim girdiğim zaman video yoktu,
hikaye yoktu, bu storyler yoktu.
Sadece bir kare fotoğraf ve altına yazılan
iki üç satır, bir mesaj, bir
cümle vardı ve ben dedim
ki yaptığım content
her ne olursa olsun ben insanları
güldürmek için 2-3 cümle altına komik
şeyler yazacağım bunun dedim ve komik
caption dediğimiz o fotoğraf yazılara
komik şeyler yazmaya başladım.
Çünkü dediğim gibi amacım her zaman
insanları güldürmekti ve insanlar beni ilk
olarak işte ay çok güzel giyiniyormuş
bu kız da, işte şöyleymiş böyleymiş diye
takip etmediler.
Onlara samimi geldim ve
onlara komik geldim.
Onları eğlendirdim.
Instagram'a girdiklerinde kafalarını
dağıtacak birkaç dakika geçirmeleri için
içerik ürettim.
Ve en önemlisi işte takipçim de artınca,
yaptığım işbirlikleri de artınca markalar
ve ajanslarla arama
kimseyi koymadım aslında
ben büyüdükçe küçüldüm.
Her zaman o saf temiz iletişimi
tercih ettim.
Bir problem olduğu zaman birlikte
çözdük yine markayla,
birlikte artık kurguları en
baştan bütün birlikte her şeyi
yönetmeye başladık.
Ve bence bu aramızdaki
sağlıklı iletişim de markalarla
bir influencer
olarak beni onlarla
daha uzun çalışmama vesile oldu.
Çok daha uzun seneli, çok daha uzun
soluklu, çok daha güven odaklı
işbirlikleri yapmaya başladık ve bu
da beni çok mutlu etti, etmeye de
devam ediyor.
Dediğim gibi hala ben oldum demiyorum,
her gün olmaya çalışıyorum, her gün
kendimi yenilemeye çalışıyorum.
Ve kesinlikle şunu söyleyebilirim:
Düşünün peşinde bir insan olarak
hala düşlerim var.
Burada bir gün konuşma yapmak bile benim
hayallerimden bir tanesiydi.
O yüzden vesile olduğunuz için de
gerçekten çok teşekkür ederim.
Benim için çok gurur dolu
birkaç dakika bu.
Çok mutluyum burada yer aldığım için
bu değerli organizasyonda.
Ve her ne iş yaparsanız yapın,
gerçekten istiyorsanız
ev hanımı oldum, istiyorsanız iş insanı
olun ama en mutlu ev hanımı olun, en
mutlu iş insanı olun.
Hedefe odaklanın.
Her zaman engeller olacak, her zaman
Hani ″bu böyle olur muymuş″
diyenler olacak.
Çünkü çok hızlı değişiyor dünya,
çok hızlı dönüşüyor.
Hiç bilmediğimiz şeyler genelde
bizi korkutuyor.
Beni de korkuttu ama pes etmedim.
B planı bile yapmadım.
Hedefe odaklandım ve gerçekten düşlerimi
çekim yasasına teslim ettim.
Çok teşekkür ederim beni
dinlediğiniz için.
Benim hikayem bu.